obviously every year there's
considerable lobbying for the Academy
Awards it's somewhat unseemly and I
think anyone who's watching television
in Los Angeles this year saw the rise of
a disturbing new trend particularly in
the Best Actress category take a look
Charlize Theron has been nominated for
another Academy Award using the same
tired old tricks
but Keira Knightley has the courage to
act
despite cheekbones so improbable they
may well be fled with God dust Keira
Knightley acting while beautiful paid
for by citizens for Keira Knightley for
Best Actress
have you seen the names of the best
actress nominees Felicity Kira
Dame Judi Charlize oh they all sound
foreign to me I don't think it's
appropriate especially during wartime
here's one Reese Witherspoon no there's
an American with a traditional name the
kind of girl I might hire to help me
with my gardening : oh that's my job
no seriously I have nothing else this
year Oscar voters have a choice
a bunch of crazy letters that make no
sense Reese before we anoint Dame Judi
Dench best actress let's hear what other
Dame's have to say about her
Judi Dench is no date perhaps a dreadful
Destry to dictate vomited on my fainting
Judi Dench took my eye out in a bar
fight
in a dame certainly not Judi Dench paid
for by names for truth a shadow
organization in no way affiliated with
Felicity Huffman
shameful our next presenter is nominated
for his role in Hustle & Flow in which
he played a pimp for those of you in the
audience by the way a pimp sort of like
an agent with a better hat please
welcome Oscar nominee Terrence Howard
they are called documentary short
subjects but they are long on impact
this year the four nominated films
examine four different aspects of war I
don't need a lot of words to tell you
what these movies are about Sudan Rwanda
Hiroshima VE Day attention must be paid
the death of Kevin Carter casualty of
the bangbang club Dan cross god sleeps
in Rwanda Kimberly a koala and Stacey
Sherman the mushroom Club Stephen
Okazaki a note of triumph the Golden Age
of Norman Corwin Corinne Marilyn and
Eric Simonson and the Oscar goes to a
note of triumph the Golden Age of Norman
Corwin foreign men and an Eric Simonson
this is the first Oscar Kareem Merriman
and Eric Simonson Eric Simonson was
previously nominated in this category
for on tiptoe gentle steps to freedom
attention must be paid indeed
I'd like to dedicate this award to
Norman Corwin normal Norman I hope
you're watching tonight and I hope your
words last forever I'd like to shake
Sheila Nevins I'd like to thank my wife
Susie and the light I'd like to thank my
producing partner here Corrine Marilyn
thank you Eric
we'd also like to thank our families
mothers fathers Amy Merck Mark Herzog
and HBO thank you very much
and I'd like to thank the Academy for
seating me next to George Clooney at the
nominees luncheon
please welcome a nominee this year for
her performance in North Country Academy
Award winner Charlize Theron
what is truth what is fiction
and what is memoir this year's
documentary features feature nominees
had little time for that debate they
spoke of only the truth some ugly some
delightful be it about politicians or
penguins courageous athletes or cowardly
executives or Believe It or Not a fish
that may change the way this planet
survives or does not and the nominees
are
Darwin's nightmare Hubert so pare Enron
the smartest guys in the room Alex
Gibney and Jason's Leo
march of the Penguins Liu chicane
Murderball henry alex-rubin and dana
Adam Shapiro
street fight Marshall hurry
and the Oscar goes to march of the
Penguins in Django
this is the first Academy Award
nomination for lucha
and Darren doll
it means thank you in penguins I'd like
to dedicate this statuette to all the
children in the world who saw that movie
in 2041 they will decide to run you or
not the treaty that protect Antarctica I
will maybe the march of the penguin
wouldn't be inspired them sorry for my
English looking at all these cocktails
tonight it's like seeing the movie again
thank you for this image thank you very
much good bye thank you thank you recipe
thank you ladies and gentlemen please
welcome a beautiful and merciful
entertainer and actress Jennifer Lopez